oh my God
hi I love you thank you starting you
into Mr Wayne no please don't um
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
but Bruce I can fix things I can save
people
save my mom
save your parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
it's not Clark my name is Cara I will
help you
interesting groups want some help
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
we're in unguarded territory
Batman what do we do we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
you have fancy friends
yo who's an Uber
exec